OK, so I don't know any other way to get into this than to just say it. I'm alarmed about something with this year's election. And yes, I know everybody is alarmed about this election. That feels like the one bipartisan thing going on in our country, is that everybody on both sides is kind of a little freaked out. But even in that context, there was this one moment where I felt like, oh, this is the world that we're living in? Like, it's this bad? This is a moment that was widely reported. I bet you saw this. September 16, Donald Trump held a press conference to say that he now believes that Barack Obama was born in the United States. And then he added this claim.
好吧，我不知道除了直接说出来还有什么别的方法能切入这个话题。我对今年的选举有些担忧。是的，我知道每个人都对这次选举感到担忧。这感觉像是我们国家唯一一件两党达成共识的事，那就是双方的所有人都感到有点恐慌。但即使在那种背景下，也有一个瞬间让我觉得，哦，这就是我们生活的世界吗？真的有这么糟糕吗？这是一个被广泛报道的时刻。我敢打赌你肯定看到了。9月16日，唐纳德·特朗普召开新闻发布会，称他现在相信巴拉克·奥巴马出生在美国。然后他补充了这一主张。
Hillary Clinton and her campaign of 2008 started the birther controversy. I finished it. I finished it. You know what I mean.
希拉里·克林顿和她2008年的竞选团队开启了“出生地争议”。我结束了它。我结束了它。你知道我的意思。
Jake Tapper was doing the live coverage of the press conference on CNN. He's their chief Washington correspondent. And he knew the whole history of the birther controversy. He had covered this for years, knew it backwards and forwards. And I got in touch with him because I wondered what it was like to be on live television when Trump announced this.
杰克·塔珀当时正在CNN直播这场新闻发布会。他是他们的首席华盛顿记者。他了解“出生地争议”的整个历史。他报道此事多年，对此了如指掌。我联系了他，因为我想知道当特朗普宣布这件事时，站在直播镜头前是什么感觉。
It was just-- it was just bizarre. And there's a famous quote from the writer Mary McCarthy who was in a feud with another writer, Lillian Hellman, and she said, "every word she says is a lie, including 'and' and 'the.'" And that's what it was, watching that press conference.
那简直——那简直太离奇了。作家玛丽·麦卡锡曾和另一位作家莉莲·海尔曼有过恩怨，她有一句名言：“她说出的每一个字都是谎言，包括‘和’（and）与‘的’（the）。”看着那场新闻发布会，感觉就是那样。
In the live coverage, Tapper almost sounds mad. Here he is on TV.
在直播报道中，塔珀听起来几乎很愤怒。这是他在电视上的表现。
Donald Trump said that Barack Obama was born in the United States, which has been a fact since 1961, but congratulations for realizing it. And then he said, Hillary Clinton started birtherism-- not true-- and I ended it-- also not true.
唐纳德·特朗普说巴拉克·奥巴马出生在美国，这自1961年以来就是一个事实，但恭喜他终于意识到了。然后他说，希拉里·克林顿开启了出生地怀疑论——这不是真的——而我结束了它——这也不是真的。
Watching you, what it seemed like is that you were feeling something like, oh, something so wrong is happening here. A lie is being born in front of my eyes. I must stop this somehow.
看着你，感觉你当时好像在想：哦，这里正在发生极其错误的事情。一个谎言正在我眼前诞生。我必须以某种方式阻止它。
I have no delusions that I can stop a lie. [CHUCKLES] But, I mean, I just wanted anybody watching who heard this to know that it was wrong. It was just false. He didn't end it. He perpetuated it. He made the birther lie bigger than it had ever been. But let me add one thing just because I do want to say one thing about--
我没有妄想自己能阻止一个谎言。（轻笑）但是，我的意思是，我只是想让每一个听到这些话的观众都知道这是错的。这纯属虚假。他并没有结束它。他延续了它。他让关于出生地的谎言变得比以往任何时候都更大。但让我补充一点，因为我确实想说一件事关于——
OK. At this point, Jake Tapper could not control himself. He ran through all the facts about how we know that Hillary Clinton's campaign did not start the birther issue, and this has been summarized plenty of places by now. Look it up if you're curious. Back in that September press conference, it was the boldness of the lie that was disturbing. Like, seriously? Do you think they were going to believe you? Or do you know that we're not going to believe you and you just don't care?
好的。此时此刻，杰克·塔珀无法控制自己了。他讲完了所有事实，说明我们如何得知希拉里·克林顿的竞选团队并没有发起“出生地争议”，这一点现在已经在很多地方被总结过了。如果你好奇，可以去查一下。在那场九月的发布会上，这种谎言的厚颜无耻令人不安。真的吗？你以为他们会相信你吗？还是说你知道我们不会相信你，但你根本不在乎？
And it didn't take long for the results of the lie to be measured. Just a few days after the Trump press conference, a Monmouth poll showed that one third of likely voters in Florida believed that Hillary Clinton started the birther controversy. I told this to Jake.
谎言的后果很快就显现出来了。在特朗普新闻发布会几天后，一项蒙茅斯民意调查显示，三分之一的佛罗里达州潜在选民认为希拉里·克林顿开启了“出生地争议”。我把这件事告诉了杰克。
[SIGHS]
（叹气）
Your reaction?
你的反应？
I mean, there is a large percentage of the country that thinks Barack Obama is a Muslim.
我的意思是，这个国家有很大比例的人认为巴拉克·奥巴马是穆斯林。
That would also be a third, about 30%. He's a Christian.
那也是三分之一，大约30%。他是基督徒。
I mean, there are a lot of people who believe a lot of wrong things. It's-- it's crazy. I mean, and it's dispiriting. I mean, it's just-- I've never seen anything like this.
我的意思是，有很多人相信很多错误的事情。这——这太疯狂了。我的意思是，这令人沮丧。我从未见过这样的事。
In just the last two weeks Donald Trump has said that Hillary Clinton may have been on drugs in the second debate. He said Hillary Clinton, quote, "meets in secret with international banks to plot the destruction of US sovereignty." During the debates, he denied saying that climate change is a hoax created by China and that Japan should get nuclear weapons even though, A, many of us remember him saying those things. It was not that long ago. And B, we can all just find this in our phones in, like, seconds.
就在过去两周，唐纳德·特朗普声称希拉里·克林顿在第二次辩论中可能吸了毒。他说希拉里·克林顿“私下会见国际银行，密谋破坏美国主权”。在辩论期间，他否认曾说过气候变化是中国制造的骗局，以及日本应该拥有核武器，尽管A，我们许多人都记得他说过这些话。那是没多久前的事。B，我们所有人只要在手机上花几秒钟就能查到。
These lies are perplexing in their nakedness. Like, he knows lots of us know these are lies, but we're in some kind of new kind of universe where that is normal and that is OK and we will just accept that.
这些谎言因其赤裸裸的特性而令人困惑。就像，他知道我们很多人都知道这是谎言，但我们处于一种新的宇宙中，谎言变成了常态，变成了可以接受的事，我们只能选择接受。
It's crazy. I mean, honestly, Joe McCarthy said crazy things in, you know, the '50s, but I've never seen accusations this wild in American politics from a major, major political figure.
这太疯狂了。说实话，约瑟夫·麦卡锡在50年代说过疯狂的话，但我从未在现代美国政治中看到一位重量级政治人物做出如此狂野的指控。
I feel worried about the country. Like, I feel worried that we live in a country where so many people distrust the fact-based media and fact-based journalists and are getting their information from other news sources and that things like this can enter the atmosphere, and then they become true for so many people. I feel worried.
我为这个国家感到担忧。我觉得我生活在一个国家，这里有太多人不仅不信任基于事实的媒体和记者，还从其他新闻源获取信息，以至于这种事情能够进入公共氛围，并让许多人信以为真。我感到担忧。
What's uncomfortable about this election is that the Trump campaign-- not the Republican Party, but the Trump campaign-- has made it so when you stand up for facts and things that are true, they act as though those facts are partisan. And that's very uncomfortable because I do not belong to either major political party. I don't think the Democratic Party or the Republican Party have answers to the nation's problems independently.
这次选举让人不安的是，特朗普竞选团队——不是共和党，而是特朗普竞选团队——已经把局面搞成这样：当你站出来捍卫事实和真相时，他们就表现得好像这些事实是党派偏见一样。这非常令人不安，因为我不属于任何一个主要政党。我不认为民主党或共和党能独立解决国家的问题。
In addition to his live coverage, Jake did a whole fact-check segment with FactCheck.org about whether Hillary Clinton started the birther movement. But, of course, he's on a network that is seen as so partisan-- it's so hated by some Republicans-- that stadiums full of people chant against them at Trump rallies.
除了直播报道，杰克还和FactCheck.org合作做了一个完整的核查片段，关于希拉里·克林顿是否发起了“出生地运动”。当然，他身处一个被视为非常有党派偏见的电视网——它被一些共和党人极度憎恨——以至于在特朗普的集会上，满场的人都在高喊反对他们。
CNN sucks!
CNN烂透了！
CNN sucks.
CNN烂透了。
CNN sucks! CNN sucks! CNN sucks! CNN sucks!
CNN烂透了！CNN烂透了！CNN烂透了！CNN烂透了！
This fact-check technique is the latest. Let me tell you what it really is. There is no fact-checking.
这种事实核查技巧是最近的手段。让我告诉你它到底是什么。根本没有所谓的事实核查。
This is Rush Limbaugh, a couple weeks ago.
这是拉什·林博几周前说的话。
The fact that The New York Times and The Washington Post and USA Today and all these other papers and networks now have fact-checkers is for one reason. It allows them to fool you. The idea that it is a fact-check story is designed to say to you that it is objective and analytically fair. And all it is is a vehicle for them to do opinion journalism under the guise of fairness, which, if you fall for it, gives it even more power.
《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》、《今日美国》以及其他所有报纸和电视网现在有核查员，原因只有一个。这让他们可以欺骗你。所谓的事实核查报道，其目的是让你觉得它是客观且分析公正的。而这实际上只是他们披着公平的外衣进行观点新闻报道的工具，如果你相信了它，反而给了它更多的力量。
So that's where we are right now. The presentation of facts is seen as partisan opinion, and then every day a barrage of untruths are presented as truth, and we're just supposed to suck it up. That's the moment we live in. That's our country right now. And this is going to continue after this election, no matter who wins. Like, this is the rest of our lives, I think, this post-truth politics. With so many of us getting our news from social media and from sources that we agree with, it's easier than ever to check if a fact is true, and facts matter less than ever.
这就是我们现在的处境。事实的呈现被视为党派观点，而每天都有大量的谎言被当作真理展示，我们只能无奈接受。这就是我们所处的时代。这就是我们现在的国家。无论谁获胜，这种情况在选举后仍会持续。我觉得，这就是我们余生要面对的“后真相政治”。随着我们中越来越多的人通过社交媒体和我们认同的来源获取新闻，检查事实真伪比以往任何时候都容易，但事实却变得比以往任何时候都无关紧要。
Well, today on our program, we take stock of how far we've fallen, and we've got some other stuff, too-- about truth and the elections. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
好吧，今天在我们的节目中，我们将评估我们堕落到了什么地步，我们也还有其他内容——关于真相和选举。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
So before I say anything else, I want to say, of course, there is solid, fact-based journalism done on the right. That is not what I'm going to be talking about right now. I'm talking about the stew of websites, talk radio, and commentary that churn out all kinds of stuff every day that is half-true or not true at all. And I feel like for months I have been thinking about this just all the time, how extreme the gap is this year between the reality put forth by the mainstream media and the reality put forth by the right-wing media. Like, why is the gap so big?
在说其他话之前，我想先说明，当然，右翼也有扎实的、基于事实的报道。我说的不是那些。我说的是那些充斥在网站、谈话电台和评论中的内容，每天都在炮制半真半假甚至完全虚假的信息。几个月来，我一直在思考这个问题：为什么主流媒体所呈现的现实与右翼媒体所呈现的现实之间的鸿沟在今年变得如此巨大？为什么差距这么大？
This was really driven home to me recently when I've been talking to my uncle Lenny on the phone. My uncle Lenny's 81. He's a retired plastic surgeon outside of San Diego. He gets all of his news from Fox and The Wall Street Journal . Not into President Obama or Hillary Clinton at all. Doesn't like Trump very much, but he's voting for him as the lesser of two evils.
最近，当我与莱尼叔叔通电话时，这一点深深触动了我。莱尼叔叔81岁了，是一位退休的整形外科医生，住在圣地亚哥郊外。他所有的新闻都来自福克斯电视台和《华尔街日报》。他一点也不喜欢奥巴马总统或希拉里·克林顿。他不太喜欢特朗普，但他认为特朗普是两害相权取其轻，所以准备投票给他。
Ira. Good morning.
艾拉。早上好。
Hey. Have you been for your walk today yet?
嘿。你今天去散步了吗？
No, I'll do that after we finish.
没，等我们聊完再去。
Really? I thought the walk was more of a first thing in the morning kind of activity.
真的吗？我以为散步应该是早上第一件事。
Well, it sometimes is, but I don't want to be too rigid.
有时是这样，但我不想太死板。
You don't want to be somebody who at night eats exactly seven almonds.
你不想成为那种晚上精确吃七颗杏仁的人。
[LAUGHS] That's right.
（笑）没错。
That's a crazy person.
那是疯子。
That's right, I'm telling my Republican uncle an Obama joke just to make him happy. A few weeks ago, I started recording conversations with my Uncle Lenny about the election. Mostly we read The New York Times together online and he would tell me what he thought of the stories. But what struck me most about these conversations is when Uncle Lenny would talk about Hillary Clinton, and especially about Barack Obama, the way he sees them. The story in his head about them seemed very out there.
没错。我给我的共和党叔叔讲了一个奥巴马笑话，只是为了让他开心。几周前，我开始录制与莱尼叔叔关于选举的对话。我们大部分时间是在网上一起看《纽约时报》，他会告诉我他对这些报道的看法。但这些对话中最让我震惊的是，当莱尼叔叔谈到希拉里·克林顿，特别是巴拉克·奥巴马时，他眼中的他们。他脑海中关于他们的故事似乎非常离谱。
Hey, can I ask, what do you think of Obama?
嘿，我可以问问，你觉得奥巴马怎么样？
I think he is an intelligent man who's never done anything worthwhile in his life. A print at--
我认为他是一个聪明人，但他这辈子从来没做过什么有价值的事。印刷——
Hey, wait, stop right there. I feel like I find that confusing. Like, he's the first black president. That's an incredible thing. That's an incredible thing.
嘿，等等，停在那儿。我觉得这很令人困惑。他是第一位黑人总统。那是一件了不起的事情。那是一件了不起的事情。
Well, symbolically it is. But his performance has been that of an amateur, which he also is. He's done nothing. He's played more rounds of golf than any president in history.
嗯，象征意义上是的。但他的表现就像个业余爱好者，他确实也是。他什么都没做。他打的高尔夫球比历史上任何一位总统都多。
I checked this later. Untrue. Dwight Eisenhower played nearly three times as much golf, Woodrow Wilson played four times more than Obama. But everything in Obama's biography seems suspicious to Lenny. Obama claims to have run the Harvard Law Review, Lenny told me. Why didn't he write a single article for them? I looked into it. He did.
我后来查过了。这是假的。德怀特·艾森豪威尔打的高尔夫球几乎是奥巴马的三倍，伍德罗·威尔逊打的次数是奥巴马的四倍。但奥巴马传记中的一切在莱尼看来似乎都很可疑。莱尼告诉我，奥巴马声称曾管理过《哈佛法律评论》。他为什么没为他们写过一篇文章？我查了一下。他写过。
And no one in his graduating class from law school can remember ever having seen him there.
而且他法学院同届没有人记得见过他。
Oh, I know somebody from his law school class who knew him.
哦，我认识一个他法学院同学，确实认识他。
Did he know him?
他认识他吗？
Yeah. Ayelet. My friend, Ayelet. She knew him in law school.
是的。艾耶莱特。我的朋友，艾耶莱特。她在法学院时认识他。
Well, that's the first person I've ever heard of who said they knew him in law school.
嗯，这是我听到的第一个说在法学院认识他的人。
Notice that we're not even out of law school yet, and already this is a narrative where the most mundane details about the man's life are doubted. Already there's this tone of conspiracy and cover-up over nothing.
注意，我们甚至还没走出法学院的话题，这就已经变成了一个叙事：这个男人生命中极其平凡的细节都被怀疑。关于这名男子，已经笼罩着一种毫无根据的阴谋和掩盖的论调。
And I bring this up because these details are part of a story that grew up around Obama in the right-wing media. He's not what he seems. He has a secret agenda. This story got traction, of course, partly because he's black, but the right-wing media would probably do the same thing with a white candidate. I mean, look at some of the things they've said about Hillary Clinton, a candidate who gives them plenty of legitimate things to criticize, and yet somehow they dwell on this nonstop speculation about her health, the earpiece she supposedly wore at the debates.
我提到这一点是因为这些细节是在右翼媒体中围绕奥巴马成长起来的故事的一部分。他不是他看起来的那样。他有一个秘密议程。当然，这个故事能产生影响，部分是因为他是黑人，但右翼媒体对于白人候选人可能也会做同样的事。我的意思是，看看他们对希拉里·克林顿说过的一些话，一个给了他们很多合法批评理由的候选人，然而他们不知为何却不停地推测她的健康状况，以及她在辩论中所谓佩戴的耳塞。
When Lenny and I talked about this, the story that he believes about Barack Obama and the one that I believe based on the mainstream media, each of us was like, really? You believe that?
当莱尼和我谈论这件事时，他相信的关于巴拉克·奥巴马的故事，和我根据主流媒体相信的故事，我们彼此都觉得：真的吗？你相信那个？
He hates what America stands for. To him it stands for slavery, it stands for exceptionalism, it stands for mal-distribution of wealth.
他憎恨美国所代表的一切。对他来说，美国代表着奴隶制，代表着例外论，代表着财富分配不均。
When Lenny talks about Obama's policies, it is all conspiracy. The president is a Muslim. He's on a mission to put Muslims in positions of power and influence. He has an ultra-left-wing agenda to erase the borders with Canada and Mexico and end the United States as we know it.
当莱尼谈论奥巴马的政策时，全是阴谋论。总统是穆斯林。他的使命是将穆斯林安插到权力和影响力的岗位上。他有一个极左的议程，要抹除与加拿大和墨西哥的边界，终结我们所知的美国。
This guy-- he wants to have one country of North America, which is composed of Canada, the United States, and part of Mexico, if not all of Mexico. That's why the existing laws, which dictate that border trespassers shall be deported, he chooses to ignore.
这个家伙——他想建立一个北美单一国家，由加拿大、美国和部分墨西哥组成，如果不是全部墨西哥的话。这就是为什么他选择无视规定边境非法越境者应被驱逐出境的法律。
Well, no, he actually deported 2.5 million people. More than any other president.
不，他实际上驱逐了250万人。比任何其他总统都多。
I don't believe that, Ira, for one minute. I don't believe that.
我不相信，艾拉，一分钟也不信。我不相信。
OK, I love my uncle. I remember crying as a kid when he went off to Vietnam. Back in the '70s and '80s, he hated liberal politicians, but he hated them because they were liberals. Like, they spent too much money, they were soft on defense. Like, that was enough. He didn't believe these kind of dark conspiracies. That's the thing that's changed, for him, and lots of people, I think.
好吧，我爱我的叔叔。我记得小时候他去越南时我曾哭过。回到70年代和80年代，他憎恨自由派政客，但他憎恨他们是因为他们是自由派。比如，他们花钱太多，国防态度软弱。比如，这就足够了。他不相信这类黑暗的阴谋。这就是变化的地方，对于他，以及我想对于很多人来说。
And those numbers that I quoted him are true. They're from the Department of Homeland Security. But facts do not have a fighting chance against this right-wing fable. And in the last few weeks since I started obsessing over all the lies that are being presented as truth right now, at some point I realized, like, oh, maybe the defining issue of this election is built around a story that isn't true. Like, honestly, this is one that I just took for granted. Like, people talk about this all the time. I hadn't given it a second thought. This issue that propelled Donald Trump to win the Republican nomination. You know the one.
而我引用给他的那些数字是真的。它们来自国土安全部。但事实在这一右翼寓言面前毫无招架之力。在过去几周，自从我开始痴迷于目前被当作真理呈现的所有谎言后，我意识到，哦，也许这场选举的核心问题建立在一个不真实的故事上。说实话，这是我一直理所当然认为的问题。人们一直在谈论这个。我没再多想。这个问题推动了唐纳德·特朗普赢得了共和党提名。你知道我说的是哪个。
I will build a great, great wall on our southern border, and I will have Mexico pay for that wall.
我会在我们的南部边境建一座伟大、伟大的墙，我会让墨西哥支付这笔费用。
Yes!
是的！
Mark my words.
记住我的话。
Yes!
是的！
The premise of the wall is that immigration is out of control. Trump told an interviewer on Fox--
筑墙的前提是移民问题失控了。特朗普在福克斯电台采访时说——
I'm not just talking Mexico. I'm talking about all over the world, they're coming through the southern border. You're going to have them coming in from the Middle East. You have them coming all over. It's not just Mexico. Everybody's pouring through the border.
我指的不只是墨西哥。我说的是全世界，他们都通过南部边境涌入。你会看到他们从中东涌入。你有来自各地的移民。不只是墨西哥。每个人都在涌过边境。
So when this became the central issue of the Republican primaries, the wall, to me, seemed like it might not be the most practical solution to this problem, but I figured this was a response to a problem facing the country. People might agree or disagree in the way that they would with any policy. But if you look into it, you come right away to this fact. And this is not a big hidden secret or anything. It shows up in news stories from time to time. This flood of people pouring across the border-- the total increase in the number of illegal immigrants in the United States each year-- is zero.
所以当这成为共和党初选的中心议题时，在我看来，这堵墙可能不是解决这个问题的最实际方案，但我认为这是对国家所面临问题的一种回应。人们可能像对待任何政策一样赞同或反对。但如果你深入研究，你马上会发现这个事实。这不是什么巨大的隐藏秘密。它不时出现在新闻报道中。这股涌过边境的人潮——美国每年非法移民总数的增长——是零。
I think he's describing an alternative reality. Or at best, a reality that existed over a decade ago.
我认为他描述的是一个替代现实。或者往好了说，是一个十多年前存在的现实。
This is Alex Nowrasteh. He's a conservative, a Republican, the immigration policy analyst at the Cato Institute, a libertarian think tank.
这是亚历克斯·诺拉斯特。他是一位保守派、共和党人，也是自由意志主义智库卡托研究所的移民政策分析师。
And so there's not a flood of illegal immigrants right now.
所以现在根本没有非法移民潮。
There isn't. There are new illegal immigrants entering the country each year, but they are offset by the illegal immigrants who are leaving.
确实没有。每年都有新的非法移民进入该国，但他们被正在离开的非法移民所抵消。
There's about 350,000 in each direction each year. And it's been that way for years, since 2009. In fact, between 2007 and 2009, at the start of the recession, when jobs dried up, the number of illegal immigrants in our country fell by about a million people. And so why do so many people believe that we're being flooded with immigrants if, in fact, we are not being flooded with immigrants? I ask that question, but of course, you know what the answer is.
每年双向大约都有35万人。这种情况已经持续多年了，自2009年以来就是这样。事实上，在2007年到2009年经济衰退初期，当工作机会减少时，我国的非法移民数量减少了大约100万人。那么，为什么这么多人相信我们正被移民潮淹没，如果事实上我们并没有被淹没呢？我问这个问题，但当然，你知道答案是什么。
I mean, the problem is out of control. We need a fence on the border like Israel has.
我的意思是，问题已经失控了。我们需要像以色列那样在边境建围栏。
All right, listen. Look at the impact it's having on our health care system, our criminal justice system, our educational system.
好了，听着。看看它对我们的医疗系统、刑事司法系统、教育系统造成的影响。
That's Ann Coulter and Sean Hannity on Fox TV two years ago. Stories about our out-of-control immigration system have been a staple of the right-wing media for years now. Ann Coulter here is talking about President Obama's immigration policy, which includes some permissive things but, like I told my Uncle Lenny, he's ordered removals of more illegal immigrants from the country than any president-- 2.5 million.
那是两年前福克斯电视上的安·库尔特和肖恩·汉尼提。关于我们移民系统失控的报道多年来一直是右翼媒体的主打内容。安·库尔特在这里谈论的是奥巴马总统的移民政策，其中包括一些宽容的举措，但正如我告诉莱尼叔叔的，他下令驱逐的非法移民比任何总统都多——250万人。
Coulter characterizes his policy towards immigrants this way.
库尔特这样描述他的移民政策。
Obama just wants-- get 'em in. Just get 'em in. And in a matter of years, they'll be voting Democrat and collecting welfare. Unfortunately, the country can't afford it. We have our own poor people we need to take care of. And we're running out of money for that. It's completely out of control.
奥巴马只是想——把他们弄进来。就是把他们弄进来。几年内，他们就会投票给民主党并领取福利。不幸的是，这个国家负担不起。我们有自己的穷人需要照顾。而我们的钱快花光了。这完全失控了。
Researching all this-- I hadn't listened to Rush Limbaugh for a while, and listening I remembered, oh right, he just makes facts up. Like, that's standard operating procedure on right-wing talk radio.
研究这一切时——我有一段时间没听拉什·林博的节目了，听的时候我想起来，哦对了，他就是凭空捏造事实。这就是右翼谈话电台的标准操作程序。
Here he is, trying to give a little immigration policy history.
这是他，试图提供一点移民政策历史。
You know, I still am amazed by the reaction I get from people when I tell them that there was zero immigration in this country from 1924 to 1965. People don't know it. It's not reported. It's never been part of history class, history education. 41 years, essentially, there was no immigration.
你知道，当人们听到我告诉他们1924年到1965年这个国家没有移民时，我依然对他们的反应感到震惊。人们不知道。它没有被报道。它从来没有成为历史课、历史教育的一部分。41年，本质上，没有移民。
Try telling people that in the midst of this debate, and they won't believe you. They'll think you're making it up. They'll think you're lying about it.
试着在这场辩论中告诉人们，他们不会相信你。他们会认为你在编造。他们会认为你在撒谎。
Well, there's a good reason they think you're making it up and lying. Millions of people became legal immigrants during that period. 8 million were granted status as permanent residents. 6.5 million became citizens, according to the federal government.
好吧，他们认为你在编造和撒谎是有充分理由的。在此期间，数百万的人成为了合法移民。根据联邦政府的数据，800万人获得了永久居民身份。650万人成为了公民。
Alex Nowrasteh, the guy from the Cato Institute, contests all the big plot points that you hear on right-wing media about immigration. That immigrants cause more crime than native born Americans, that they are a drain on taxpayers, and, of course, that they are flooding across the border. I wonder what it was like for him to see those ideas propagated so often, so broadly, and taken so seriously by so many people. Like, to the point where a candidate is proposing a wall and then stadiums cheer.
亚历克斯·诺拉斯特，那个卡托研究所的人，反驳了你在右翼媒体上听到的关于移民的所有重大论点。说移民造成的犯罪比本土出生的美国人多，说他们是纳税人的负担，当然，还有他们正涌过边境。我很好奇，看着这些观点被如此频繁、广泛地传播，并被如此多人如此认真地对待，对他来说是什么感觉。比如，到了一个候选人提议筑墙，然后全场欢呼的地步。
It's incredibly depressing to see people base their policy opinions on things that just simply are not true, that are basically just myths. Like, to say otherwise, to state what the facts otherwise are, gets you labeled a traitor or gets you labeled sort of anti-American, or gets you labeled a socialist. All things which I am not. Absolutely not. So it's depressing, and it's hard to fight against.
看到人们基于完全不真实、本质上只是神话的东西来表达政策观点，这令人极其沮丧。比如，说出相反的事实，会让你被贴上叛徒的标签，或者被贴上反美、社会主义者的标签。所有这些我都不是。绝对不是。所以这很令人沮丧，也很难对抗。
Wait, wait. Just walk me through that. Are you in a situation often where you're trying to present these facts and people who you feel like are your natural allies don't believe you?
等等，等等。只是带我梳理一下。你是否经常遇到这种情况，你试图呈现这些事实，而那些你觉得是天然盟友的人却不相信你？
Frequently. Frequently. I travel across the country all the time to speak to different groups. Out West in Arizona, in California, a lot of conservative and Republican clubs. And just the quantity of skepticism for well-established facts on this topic is astounding.
经常。经常。我经常去全国各地向不同的团体发表演讲。在美国西部，在亚利桑那州，在加利福尼亚州，有很多保守派和共和党俱乐部。仅仅是人们对这个主题上已确立的事实的怀疑程度就令人震惊。
And are you often in the situation where people just think you're some sort of pinko, like you're working for Obama and Hillary Clinton?
你是否经常处于那种人们认为你是某种赤色分子，好像你是在为奥巴马和希拉里·克林顿工作？
All the time. Increasingly, all the time. When I go on the radio people, will call in and they'll say something to the effect of, oh, well, of course you believe that. You also think we should make guns illegal. You know, not knowing that I'm personally quite a gun nut and I have the exact opposite opinion. So it's like, a lot of political assumptions go into this.
一直都是。越来越多，一直都是。当我去电台时，人们会打来电话，他们会说类似的话：哦，好吧，你当然会相信那个。你也认为我们应该取缔枪支。你知道，他们不知道我个人其实是一个枪支狂热者，我的观点正好相反。所以就像，很多政治假设被预设进去了。
Alex used this phrase that I'd never heard before-- Patriotic Correctness. It's like political correctness, but the right-wing version of that. Like, if you say that there is no flood of immigrants coming across the border, well, that is just out of bounds. That's not something you say. You are not patriotically correct. So people do not even give him a chance.
亚历克斯用了这个我从未听说过的短语——“爱国正确”。这就像政治正确，但这是右翼的版本。比如，如果你说没有移民潮涌过边境，那么这就越界了。这不是你能说的话。你不符合“爱国正确”。所以人们甚至不给他机会。
I think that's because politics, at some level, is more than the sum of facts. It's an identity. You know, you're a Republican or you're a Democrat, and then there's a whole set of stories and beliefs that go with that identity. And facts do not have much power against a set of beliefs. Those of us in the fact business-- our facts are puny compared to that.
我想这是因为政治，在某种程度上，不仅仅是事实的总和。它是一种认同。你知道，你是共和党人还是民主党人，然后有一整套与该认同相伴的故事和信仰。而事实在这一套信仰面前没什么力量。我们这些搞事实工作的——我们的事实在那种力量面前微不足道。
Act two, Judges with Grudges.
第二幕，带着偏见的法官。
So let's turn now, in this election year, to the story of one little referendum on one state ballot. Here's how we heard about it. A few years ago we devoted an entire episode of our program to the story of this judge in Georgia, a woman named Amanda Williams. Judge Williams had a history of doing things that it seemed like judges just should not do. For instance, she put a teenager named Lindsey Dills into solitary confinement for an indefinite period of time. Indefinite, like, until further notice. No end date. No access to a lawyer. Lindsey told me--
那么让我们在这一选举年，转向一个州选票上一项小公投的故事。以下是我们听到它的方式。几年前，我们将节目整整一集献给了乔治亚州这位法官的故事，一位名叫阿曼达·威廉姆斯的女性。威廉姆斯法官有做一些法官似乎不应该做的事情的历史。例如，她将一名叫琳赛·迪尔斯的青少年置于无限期的单独监禁中。无限期，就是直到另行通知。没有结束日期。无法接触律师。琳赛告诉我说——
I cried a lot. Pretty much all the time I was crying. I was like, how is this happening? How is this ethical? Where am I? Like, am I in a foreign country? Have I killed someone that I don't know about? Like, how does what I did merit that type of treatment? But there's nothing I can do about it, because I can't even use the phone. I can't even send a letter.
我哭了很多。几乎一直都在哭。我当时想，这是怎么发生的？这怎么符合道德？我在哪里？就像，我在国外吗？我杀了一个我不知道的人吗？就像，我做的事怎么值得那种对待？但我对此无能为力，因为我甚至不能用电话。我甚至不能写信。
Finally, during this confinement, Lindsey tried to kill herself. We attempted to interviewed Judge Williams about this and some other issues, but she declined to comment on those issues. So while I was working on that story, an official commission in Georgia that is charged with investigating judicial ethics violations was also looking into Judge Williams. The commission later filed a 14-count ethics complaint against her. Shortly after that, Judge William stepped down from the bench.
最后，在监禁期间，琳赛试图自杀。我们曾试图采访威廉姆斯法官关于此及其他问题，但她拒绝评论。所以在我处理那个故事时，乔治亚州一个负责调查司法道德违规的官方委员会也在调查威廉姆斯法官。该委员会后来对她提起了14项道德指控。不久之后，威廉姆斯法官辞职下台。
The commission that filed those charges-- before we did that story, I didn't even know anything like this existed, but all states have them. Sometimes they're called JQCs, for Judicial Qualifications Commissions-- that's what the one in Georgia is called-- and they are the way that we as a country have come up with for getting rid of judges who do bad things. Georgia's JQC seemed pretty impressive. They have a tiny staff, seven members, who work pro bono. They are not paid. And in the past decade, in addition to Judge Williams, over 60 judges in Georgia have stepped down after being investigated.
那个提起指控的委员会——在我们做那个故事之前，我甚至不知道这世界上还存在这样的机构，但所有州都有。有时它们被称为JQC，即司法资格委员会——这就是乔治亚州那个委员会的名称——它们是我们作为一个国家想出来的，用来清除做坏事的法官的办法。乔治亚州的JQC看起来相当令人印象深刻。他们员工极少，七名成员，义务工作。他们没有报酬。在过去十年里，除了威廉姆斯法官，乔治亚州有60多名法官在被调查后辞职。
So we did that story years ago. And then a few months ago, one of my sources in Georgia called me to say, guess what? Lawmakers in Georgia were trying to neuter the JQC, and the whole thing was going to be on the ballot this fall. And, OK, I know that state-level politics can be kind of nutty sometimes, but my question was, OK, here's an example of a government agency doing a good job. It would seem like a very low cost. Like, how can something like that happen, right? Like, why was this on the ballot? It seemed like the only people who would benefit from weakening the JQC would be bad judges. Like, that is not a big constituency. Like, who's going to vote for that in a democracy?
所以我们几年前做了那个故事。然后几个月前，我在乔治亚州的一位消息人士打电话告诉我，猜怎么着？乔治亚州的议员正试图阉割JQC，而且整个事情今年秋天会出现在选票上。而且，好吧，我知道州级政治有时可能有点疯狂，但我的问题是，好吧，这是一个政府机构做好事的一个例子。这似乎成本很低。就像，这种事怎么可能发生，对吧？就像，为什么这个会出现在选票上？似乎削弱JQC的唯一受益者就是坏法官。那可不是一个庞大的选民群体。就像，谁会在民主国家投票支持那个？
Well, one of our producers, Dave Kestenbaum, flew to Atlanta to figure out what was going on. A quick warning to podcast and internet listeners. There is some language in the story that we have un-beeped here in the internet version of our show. If you prefer a beeped version of our program, go to our website.
嗯，我们的制作人之一，戴夫·凯斯滕鲍姆，飞往亚特兰大去弄清楚发生了什么。给播客和互联网听众的一个快速警告。在这个故事中，我们互联网版本节目中有些语言没有被消音。如果你更喜欢消音版本，请前往我们的网站。
To understand this referendum, you first need a little background on Georgia's JQC, and just how aggressive it's been at going after judges. More than anyone, the person who probably embodies the boldness and zeal of the mission is Richard Hyde. Hyde is a commission member. He was their paid investigator for a decade. I've heard him describe himself as "the point of the spear," and once at a legislative hearing under oath, "the turd in the punchbowl."
要理解这次公投，你首先需要了解乔治亚州JQC的一点背景，以及它在打击法官方面是多么激进。比起任何人，最能体现其使命的果敢和热情的人可能是理查德·海德。海德是委员会成员。他当了十年的带薪调查员。我听他形容自己是“矛尖”，有一次在立法听证会上宣誓时，他自称是“潘趣酒碗里的那坨屎”。
When I asked him about the 60 judges that had resigned, and that that seemed like a lot, he shrugged.
当我问他关于那60名辞职的法官，以及这看起来是不是太多了时，他耸了耸肩。
Georgia judges are no different than judges around the country. What is different is the way we investigate judges.
乔治亚州的法官和全国各地的法官没什么不同。不同的是我们调查法官的方式。
Hyde calls it "the Georgia method." He's traveled to Ukraine to train officials there how to do it. Basically, they'll get some tip about something a judge may have done, they'll investigate the hell out of it, and if they find something, they'll confront the judge. Hyde says he'll explain that the judge has the right to a public trial, but then he'll just say this--
海德称之为“乔治亚方法”。他曾前往乌克兰培训那里的官员如何做。基本上，他们会得到一些关于法官可能做了某事的线索，他们会彻底调查清楚，如果发现了一些事情，他们就会与法官对质。海德说，他会解释法官有公开审判的权利，但他只会说这句话——
Judge, given the nature of the allegations, if true, what do you think the appropriate sanction from the commission should be? And about 90 percent of the time, those judges would say, I think it is time that I leave.
法官，鉴于指控的性质，如果属实，你认为委员会应该给予什么适当的制裁？而大约90%的情况下，那些法官会说，我想是我该离开的时候了。
Honestly, I can't tell if that question is some high-minded way of trying to engage a judge's inner sense of duty, or just a fancy version of, we can do this the easy way or the hard way.
老实说，我看不出这个问题是一种试图唤醒法官内心责任感的高尚方式，还是仅仅是“我们可以轻松处理，也可以强硬处理”的一种华丽说法。
Judges are powerful people, but Hyde is not easily intimidated. He used to be a street cop. Back then he would tow the cars of state lawmakers who had double-parked near the state capitol. Once, he shot an escaped chimpanzee who was attacking people on a street. He felt bad about that. In the Atlanta school testing scandal where teachers were doctoring students' test scores, it was Hyde who got an elementary school teacher to wear a wire, which broke the whole thing open. One news story quoted someone saying they would "rather have a wasting disease than to be investigated by Hyde." He's just so relentless.
法官是权力人物，但海德并不容易被吓倒。他曾经是一名街头警察。那时，他会拖走那些在州议会大厦附近违规停车的州议员的车。有一次，他射杀了一只正在街上攻击人的逃脱黑猩猩。他对此感到很难过。在亚特兰大学校测试丑闻中，教师篡改学生测试分数，是海德让一名小学教师戴上窃听器，从而揭开了整个事情。一篇新闻报道引用某人的话说，他们“宁愿得消耗性疾病，也不愿被海德调查”。他就是如此无情。
But Hyde says the JQC is not out to get judges. They're just trying to protect the public. If a judge slips up, they try to work things out. Here's an example of that. When I went to interview Hyde, he'd brought along a transcript of a case they'd had to look into. It's a murder case, and the defendant is refusing to use a lawyer. Just refusing. He starts actually swearing at the judge, using profanity. The judge tries to reason with him, and then this happens. I had Hyde read this part.
但海德说，JQC不是要整法官。他们只是试图保护公众。如果法官犯了错，他们会尝试协调解决。这里有一个例子。当我去采访海德时，他随身带了一份他们必须调查的案件的记录。这是一个谋杀案，被告拒绝使用律师。就是拒绝。他开始实际上咒骂法官，使用亵渎语言。法官试图与他讲道理，然后发生了这件事。我让海德读了这一部分。
The judge-- listen to me.
法官——听我说。
The defendant-- fuck you.
被告——去你妈的。
Listen to me.
法官——听我说。
The defendant-- go fuck yourself.
被告——去你妈的。
The judge-- I'm finding you in contempt of court.
法官——我判定你藐视法庭。
I don't care.
被告——我不在乎。
I know you don't, and I sentence you to 20 days for that. And if you say anything else, I'm going to add 20 days for everything you say.
法官——我知道你不在乎，我判你20天监禁。如果你再说任何话，你每说一句我就加20天。
The defendant-- fuck you.
被告——去你妈的。
The judge-- 40 days.
法官——40天。
The defendant-- fuck you, again.
被告——去你妈的，再来一遍。
60 days.
法官——60天。
The defendant-- go fuck yourself.
被告——去你妈的。
The judge-- a year.
法官——一年。
The defendant-- your mama.
被告——你妈。
The judge-- 10 years.
法官——10年。
The defendant-- suck my dick.
被告——舔我的鸡巴。
The judge-- you know something? This is going to be an interesting trial.
法官——你知道吗？这将是一场有趣的审判。
The defendant threatens to kill the judge's family, and the judge just kind of loses it. When the defendant says he's going to masturbate in court, the judge says, why don't you do that right now? Do it now. Do it now. Hyde says the judge had a stellar record before this, so the JQC, when it heard about it, did what it often does. It had the judge in for a little talk, to discuss what had happened and how to avoid it again. They publicly reprimanded him and the judge went back to being a judge.
被告威胁要杀死法官的家人，而法官只是有点失控了。当被告说要在法庭上手淫时，法官说，你为什么不现在就做？现在做。现在做。海德说，这位法官在此之前记录非常出色，所以JQC在听说这件事后，做了它经常做的事。它让这位法官来进行了一次小谈话，讨论发生了什么以及如何再次避免它。他们公开谴责了他，法官回去继续做他的法官。
But Hyde says there are more extreme cases. Like the time a judge, in court, took a gun out and told the witness she was, quote, "killing her case and might as well shoot her lawyer." And then there was this other time. An attorney said that a judge hearing her case had sexually harassed her, at one point leaving her a phone message in which he, the judge, identified himself as Santa Claus and said the following, "hey, hey, hey, little girl. Want to sit on Santa's face?" The woman gave the recording of that message to Richard Hyde, and Hyde went out to talk to the judge.
但海德说还有更极端的案件。比如有一次，一名法官在法庭上拔出一把枪，告诉证人说她在，引用，“毁掉她的案子，还不如开枪打死她的律师”。还有另一次。一名律师说，审理她案件的法官曾对她进行性骚扰，有一次给她留了一条电话留言，他，法官，自称是圣诞老人并说了以下内容，“嘿，嘿，嘿，小女孩。想坐在圣诞老人的脸上吗？”这名女子把那条留言的录音给了理查德·海德，海德去找了那位法官。
I met with him at his courthouse. And he's got an office full of people doing whatever it was that was going on, and I identified myself and asked him if we could talk in private. So we walked outside, and I'm asking him questions about, have you ever sexually harassed any of the women in front of you? Did you ever make any sexual demands? Did you ever leave a message on somebody's voicemail inappropriately? He denied all of that. So I said, well, then we have a problem because somebody is lying to me. Either the complainant or you are lying.
我在他的法院见了他。他的办公室里有一群人在做着不管是什么的事情，我表明了身份，问我们是否可以私下谈谈。所以我们走到外面，我问他问题，有没有对你面前的任何女性进行过性骚扰？有没有提出过任何性要求？有没有在某人的语音信箱上留过不适当的留言？他否认了所有这些。所以我说，好吧，那我们有问题了，因为有人在对我撒谎。要么是投诉人，要么是你撒谎。
So I played-- we sat in my truck, and I played the recording, and he listened to it.
所以我就播放——我们坐在我的卡车里，我播放了录音，他听了。
What was his reaction when you played him the voicemail? He just told you he didn't do it.
当你播放那个语音留言时他的反应是什么？他刚才还告诉你他没做过。
He became very emotional. He wept. He walked in his office, got a piece of stationery out and hand-wrote a letter to the governor, resigning and agreeing never to be a judge again.
他变得非常激动。他哭了。他走进办公室，拿出一张信纸，手写了一封给州长的信，辞职并同意永远不再做法官。
Before we get to why some in the legislature wanted to dismantle and remake the JQC, it's interesting to see how badly they wanted to change it. This is not an easy thing to do. In Georgia, like in a lot of states, the Judicial Qualifications Commission, this entity with the power to remove judges for unethical behavior, is written into the Constitution. One lawyer who helped put it there-- this was back in the '70s-- told me it was put in the Constitution expressly to avoid political tampering. People make a basic separation of powers argument. Keep the JQC independent. If lawmakers got their hands on it, they might pressure JQC members to drop cases against their friends, or go after a judge they don't like.
在我们讨论为什么立法机构中的一些人想要拆除并重组JQC之前，看看他们是多么迫切地想要改变它是很有趣的。这不是一件容易的事。在乔治亚州，像在许多州一样，司法资格委员会，这个有权移除不道德行为法官的实体，被写进了宪法。一位帮助把它写进去的律师——那是70年代的事了——告诉我，把它放进宪法是为了明确避免政治篡改。人们提出了一个基本的权力分立论点。保持JQC的独立性。如果立法者插手，他们可能会向JQC成员施压，要求放弃针对他们朋友的案件，或者去针对他们不喜欢的法官。
But this past January, one Friday afternoon, House Resolution 1113 was introduced, a bill proposing an amendment to the Constitution that would abolish the JQC and allow lawmakers to remake it however they saw fit.
但今年1月，一个星期五下午，众议院第1113号决议被提出，该法案提议修改宪法，废除JQC并允许立法者以他们认为合适的任何方式重组它。
Lester Tate, at the time a member of the JQC, says he'd pulled into his driveway when someone called with the news. Tate was furious. It seemed like a straight-up power grab. He told me he saw HR 1113 as an act of war.
莱斯特·泰特，当时是JQC的成员，说有人打电话告诉他这个消息时，他刚把车开进车道。泰特非常愤怒。这看起来是一场直截了当的夺权。他告诉我，他把HR 1113视为战争行为。
Clearly it was. You know, when the Japanese bombed Pearl Harbor, we had no knowledge that it was coming. Nothing's been said about this to anybody, and then all of a sudden you introduce a bill like this, I think it's pretty clear that a sneak attack has been launched.
这显然就是。你知道，当日本人轰炸珍珠港时，我们一点都不知道它要来了。没有人对任何人说过什么，然后突然间你就提出了这样的法案，我认为很明显这是一次偷袭。
It's not quite as bad as Pearl Harbor.
这还没像珍珠港那么糟。
Well, no ships were sunk in the process, but the analogy, I think, still holds true.
嗯，不，过程中没有船沉没，但我认为这个比喻依然适用。
There's one little detail worth pointing out here. It gets mentioned in a lot of the local news coverage. One of the sponsors of the bill is a representative named Johnny Caldwell. Before being a lawmaker, Caldwell was a judge. The judge who was accused of leaving the Santa Claus "sit on my face" voicemail. Representative Caldwell declined our request for an interview.
这里有一个值得指出的小细节。它在很多地方新闻报道中被提及。该法案的发起人之一是一位名叫约翰尼·考德威尔的议员。在成为立法者之前，考德威尔曾是一名法官。那位被指控留下圣诞老人“坐在我脸上”语音留言的法官。考德威尔议员拒绝了我们的采访请求。
Secretary will read HR 1113.
书记员将宣读HR 1113。
House Resolution 1113, by Representative--
众议院第1113号决议，由议员——
Altering the Constitution is a big deal. For starters, any proposed change has to be approved by 2/3 of the House and 2/3 of the Senate. Then the voters have to approve it as well. Republicans introduced the measure, and they had the votes in the House. But in the Senate, it was tight. If all the Republicans voted for it, the bill would pass.
修改宪法是一件大事。首先，任何提议的变更必须获得众议院2/3和参议院2/3的批准。然后选民也必须批准它。共和党人提出了这项措施，他们在众议院拥有票数。但在参议院，情况很紧张。如果所有共和党人都投票支持，法案就会通过。
But here they had a problem. A man named Josh McKoon. McKoon is a Republican who seems to enjoy not voting Republican sometimes. He's loved politics since he was a kid. Favorite President, Calvin Coolidge. McKoon is chair of the Senate Judiciary Committee, and he thought taking the JQC out of the Constitution, letting politicians remake it however they wanted, sounded like a terrible idea.
但在这里他们遇到了一个问题。一个名叫乔希·麦昆的人。麦昆是一位似乎有时喜欢不投票支持共和党的共和党人。他从小就热爱政治。最喜欢的总统是卡尔文·柯立芝。麦昆是参议院司法委员会主席，他认为把JQC从宪法中拿出来，让政客们随心所欲地重组，听起来是个可怕的主意。
And I just remember somebody mentioning, hey, this is coming up. And I kind of dismissed it because it seemed so absurd.
我只记得有人提到，嘿，这事要来了。我有点不理会它，因为它看起来太荒谬了。
Chair recognizes Senator 29.
主席认可第29号参议员。
Thank you, Mr. President.
谢谢，主席先生。
This is McKoon on one of the last nights of the legislative session for the year. The bill, at this point, has failed to pass once, but it's coming up for another vote. McKoon doesn't shout. His tones is more, (INCREDULOUS) seriously?
这是麦昆在今年立法会议最后几个晚上之一的表现。该法案此时已经失败过一次，但它即将进行另一次投票。麦昆没有大喊大叫。他的语调更多是（不可置信）真的吗？
Um, it's just really hard to wrap my brain around the fact that we are going to do this. We ought to think long and hard before we say we're going to abolish the independent constitutional agency that has overseen judicial ethics in this state for the last four decades.
嗯，真的很难想象这样一个事实：我们要这样做。在我们说要废除在过去四十年里一直监督该州司法道德的独立宪法机构之前，我们应该深思熟虑。
McKoon is particularly upset about how the legislature would remake the JQC. The JQC has seven members, and lawmakers want to give the Speaker of the House and the president of the Senate the power to pick four of the seven seats. Currently they pick zero.
麦昆对立法机构将如何重组JQC感到特别不安。JQC有七名成员，立法者想给予众议院议长和参议院主席权力去挑选七个席位中的四个。目前他们挑选零个。
I looked into what other states do. According to the Center for Judicial Ethics, only one state gives lawmakers the power to pick a majority of its JQC members.
我研究了其他州的做法。根据司法道德中心，只有一个州给予立法者挑选其JQC成员多数的权力。
We are taking, literally, the only bright spot in the network of ethics and conflict of interest laws in state government and we are throwing them in the garbage. And for what?
我们实际上正在采取州政府道德和利益冲突法律网络中唯一的亮点，并把它们扔进垃圾桶。为了什么？
McKoon began to suspect that this was all about personal gripes, or lawmakers who are friends with judges who the JQC had investigated. The Speaker of the House, in particular, seemed unusually determined to overhaul this little commission. This became very clear in the final days of the session. Time was running out to pass the bill. McKoon says he and the other Republican senators got pulled into this urgent meeting.
麦昆开始怀疑这全是关于个人不满，或者是与JQC调查过的法官有交情的立法者。众议院议长尤其显得异常坚决要彻底整改这个小委员会。这在会议的最后几天变得非常清楚。通过该法案的时间所剩无几。麦昆说，他和共和党参议员被叫去参加了这个紧急会议。
We were told that the Speaker had made it clear, if we did not pass the JQC constitutional amendment, that he would, quote, "shut the building down." Meaning, the House would not consider any Senate legislation.
我们被告知议长已经明确表示，如果我们不通过JQC宪法修正案，他就会，引用，“关闭大楼”。这意味着，众议院将不审议任何参议院立法。
Until the JQC got passed.
直到JQC获得通过。
Correct.
正确。
Two days before the end of the session-- it's after 9:00 PM-- the bill comes up for a final vote.
会议结束前两天——时间已过晚上9点——该法案进行了最终投票。
--is agreed to. All those in favor, vote aye. Those opposed, no. The Secretary will unlock the machine.
——已达成一致。赞成者，投票赞成。反对者，否。书记员将解锁机器。
[BELL RINGS]
（铃响）
A minute later, the bill narrowly passes. If you look at the breakdown, you can see what happened. One Democrat crossed party lines and voted in favor. A woman named Donzella James. She declined to talk with us, but a newspaper reporter who was in the room, Greg Bluestein with The Atlanta Journal-Constitution , says it was totally clear what had happened. Republicans had made a trade. They'd offered to support a bill that she'd been trying to get through for years, to turn the area where she lived into a city. The bill was to put a referendum on the ballot about it. Bluestein says he knows this trade happened because a Republican, at this point, walked up and just started narrating what was going on.
一分钟后，法案以微弱优势通过。如果你看看细分，你可以看到发生了什么。一位民主党人越过党派路线投票支持。一位名叫唐泽拉·詹姆斯的女士。她拒绝与我们交谈，但在场的报纸记者，来自《亚特兰大宪法报》的格雷格·布鲁斯坦，说发生了什么完全清楚。共和党人做了一个交易。他们主动提出支持她多年来一直试图通过的一项法案，将她居住的地区变成一个城市。该法案是为了就此在选票上进行公投。布鲁斯坦说，他知道这个交易发生了，因为一个共和党人在此时走过来并开始叙述正在发生的事情。
He said, she stuck with us, now we'll stick with her. So this was-- this was-- there was no effort to hide that there was horse trading going on here.
他说，她坚持我们，现在我们要坚持她。所以这就是——这就是——完全没有试图掩盖这里正在进行的马匹交易。
Like, you watched it happen.
就像，你看着它发生。
Oh, literally watched it happen. And had people openly talk about it.
哦，字面意义上看着它发生。而且有人公开谈论它。
In case there was any doubt, the very next bill brought up was for the city referendum, which passed easily. Lawmakers were willing to create a city to get control of the JQC.
万一还有什么疑问，随后提出的下一个法案就是关于城市公投的，它轻易通过了。立法者为了获得对JQC的控制权，愿意创造一个城市。
If you're wondering why this was such a priority, why the Speaker of the House seemed so determined to push this through, Josh McKoon, the Republican, wondered that too. So we asked around.
如果你想知道为什么这成为如此优先的事项，为什么众议院议长似乎如此决心推动它，共和党人乔希·麦昆也感到好奇。所以我们四处打听。
You know, why is this such a high-profile-- why is this thing moving so quickly? And the answer was, this is a priority of the Speaker of the House. And then when you would say, well, why does he care about the function in the JQC? It was, well, this all goes back to his conflict with the state bar.
你知道，为什么这是一个如此高调——为什么这件事发展得如此之快？答案是，这是众议院议长的优先事项。然后当你问，嗯，他为什么关心JQC的功能？答案是，这全是关于他与州律师协会的冲突。
The state bar. This takes a little explaining, but stick with me. The speaker has a longstanding, very heated feud with the state bar. The bar has filed charges against him that could get him disbarred. I've read some of the back and forth. It sounds like people yelling at each other in the most formal language possible. Like, "it is clear that absurdity is no prohibition on the actions of the state bar."
州律师协会。这需要一点解释，但请坚持听我讲。议长与州律师协会有着长期的、非常激烈的恩怨。律师协会对他提起了可能导致他被除名的指控。我读过一些来回的往来。听起来就像人们在用尽可能正式的语言互相大喊大叫。比如，“很明显，荒谬并不能阻止州律师协会的行动。”
What does all this have to do with the JQC? The bar currently gets to a appoint three members of the JQC. If these changes go through, the bar will get zero. To McKoon, it looked like revenge. The House Speaker declined to comment.
这一切与JQC有什么关系？律师协会目前有权任命三名JQC成员。如果这些变更通过，律师协会将获得零个。对麦昆来说，这看起来像是报复。众议院议长拒绝评论。
This is the story I initially heard, at least, about how petty politics, personal gripes, and a Santa Claus voicemail were threatening to gut an institution that was doing its job, and doing it quite well. It's the kind of story that one side of an issue tells itself all the time, I think. And when you hear something like that, it can be hard to imagine any other version. But, of course, there is another side. And on that side, another story involving the very same events. So come with me. Let's cross over to that other side. Let's try to get to the bottom of this one ballot measure in one state.
这至少是我最初听到的关于琐碎的政治、个人不满和圣诞老人语音留言如何威胁到一个正在履行其职责并且做得非常好的机构的故事。我认为，这是一方在处理某个议题时经常告诉自己的故事。当你听到这样的事情时，很难想象还有其他版本。但当然，还有另一面。在那一面，有另一个涉及同样事件的故事。所以跟我来。让我们跨越到那一面。让我们试着弄清楚这一州公投的真相。
I am here so that the JQC never again abuses its power to the detriment of those who serve and the public we all serve.
我在这里是为了让JQC不再滥用其权力去损害那些服务的人和我们共同服务的公众。
This is Cynthia Becker testifying at a recent hearing before lawmakers. Until recently, she was a judge. And in the alternate narrative of this story, she's the main character.
这是辛西娅·贝克在最近一次立法者听证会上的证词。直到最近，她还是一名法官。在这个故事的替代叙事中，她是主角。
I heard with dismay a former director testify last week, between 2010 and 2014, 50 judges were removed. We are not trophies. We are not scalps. That's not a good start.
我上周惊恐地听到一名前主管作证说，2010年至2014年间，50名法官被免职。我们不是战利品。我们不是头皮。那不是一个好的开始。
Becker was investigated by the JQC and was visibly furious about how it all went down. She says she was called in to talk to JQC members about some complaint, but she wasn't told what it was. Turns out, there was a question about whether she had denied somebody bail-- a former school superintendent who ended up spending four days in jail.
贝克被JQC调查，并对这一切如何发生感到明显愤怒。她说她被叫去与JQC成员谈论一些投诉，但她没被告知是什么。事实证明，有人质疑她是否拒绝了某人的保释——一名前学校主管，最终在监狱里待了四天。
She says when she got to the JQC one of the members just started yelling at her.
她说当她到达JQC时，其中一名成员就开始对她大喊大叫。
One commission member was so over the top that, if he had conducted himself that way in a court room, deputies would have escorted him out of the courtroom. He was standing, he was red-faced, he was pointing his finger at me, lecturing me--
一位委员会成员非常过分，如果他在法庭上表现成那样，法警会把他带出法庭。他站着，满脸通红，指着我，教训我——
Who was that?
那是谁？
That was Mr. Tate.
那是泰特先生。
Lester Tate, the commission member you heard comparing the JQC bill to the attack on Pearl Harbor. According to notes from that meeting, at one point, Judge Becker started weeping. The whole thing, she says, was recorded without her knowledge.
莱斯特·泰特，你刚才听到他把JQC法案比作珍珠港事件的那位委员会成员。根据那次会议的记录，有一次，贝克法官开始哭泣。她说，整个过程是在她不知情的情况下被录音的。
Another judge who testified said that the same JQC member, Lester Tate, behaved improperly in his court. According to an affidavit by a court clerk Tate, quote, "turned bright red all over and got extremely upset." A month later, Richard Hyde, the crusading investigator you heard at the beginning of the story, showed up demanding to see documents. A court clerk wrote, quote, "he was questioning me like a drill sergeant in the army. He almost brought me to tears. I have never had anyone treat me like this." The judge, Mitchell Scoggins, says Hyde then went through his things.
另一位作证的法官说，同一位JQC成员莱斯特·泰特在法庭上表现不当。根据法庭书记员泰特的宣誓书，引用，“全身变得通红，变得非常不安。”一个月后，你在故事开头听到的那位十字军调查员理查德·海德，出现要求查看文件。一位法庭书记员写道，引用，“他审问我像军队里的军士长。他几乎让我流泪。我从未让人这样对待过我。”米切尔·斯考金斯法官说，海德随后翻看了他的东西。
the reason I know he did is because we pulled our security camera video, and we could see Mr. Hyde in there with my clerk-- just those two people-- going through paperwork on my desk. And I didn't appreciate that. I didn't like that at all.
我知道他这样做的原因是，因为我们调取了我们的安全摄像头视频，我们可以看到海德先生和我的书记员在那里——只有他们两个人——翻看我桌上的文件。我对此不感激。我一点也不喜欢那样。
Lester Tate denies doing anything wrong in either case. In fact, he's resigned in protest over this whole effort to remake the JQC.
莱斯特·泰特否认在任何一个案件中做错任何事。事实上，他已经辞职抗议整个重组JQC的努力。
Richard Hyde told me things did get heated when he came by court that day, but here's what he said about searching that judge's desk.
理查德·海德告诉我，那天他去法院时事情确实变得激烈了，但关于搜查法官桌子，他是这么说的——
I looked through the papers on the public bench, yes. That is not his bench. That bench belongs to the people of this state. Those documents belong to the people of this state. They were in plain view, they looked out of place, and I looked through them. I make no apologies for that.
我确实翻看了公共席上的文件。那不是他的席位。那席位属于这个州的人民。那些文件属于这个州的人民。它们放在显眼的地方，它们看起来格格不入，所以我翻看了它们。我不为此道歉。
Richard Hyde has publicly said that the JQC owes a couple judges an apology for how their cases were handled-- but just a couple. Which of those judges who step down do you really want back on the bench, he asks? Most of the complaints, he says, are just from a few people.
理查德·海德公开表示，JQC确实欠几位法官一个道歉，因为他们的案件处理方式——但仅限几位。你真的希望那些辞职的法官中哪位回到法官席上吗？他问。他说，大部分投诉仅仅来自少数人。
Those are the five empty beer cans in the back of a pickup truck going down a dirt road.
那些是皮卡车后座里五个空啤酒罐，在泥路上颠簸。
Hyde was quick to say that the vast majority of judges do a fine job, under difficult circumstances. But, he says, sitting up there in that black robe with the gavel, it can go to some people's heads.
海德很快表示，绝大多数法官在困难环境下工作出色。但是，他说，坐在那穿黑袍拿木槌的地方，它会让一些人冲昏头脑。
People stand up when they walk in the room, they stand up when they leave. They bring them coffee, they laugh at their dumb jokes. They tell them how smart, thin, tall, and funny they are. It's black robe syndrome, is what I call it.
人们在他们走进房间时站起来，在他们离开时站起来。他们给他们拿咖啡，他们对他们的愚蠢笑话大笑。他们告诉他们他们是多么聪明、瘦、高和有趣。这就是我所称的黑袍综合症。
One way to summarize the criticism of the JQC is that some of its members have fallen prey to their own version of black robe syndrome. After all, there is the power of being a judge. But then there is the power of judging the judges.
总结对JQC的批评的一种方式是，它的一些成员成了他们自己版本的黑袍综合症的受害者。毕竟，拥有法官的权力是一种权力。但评判法官的权力则是另一种权力。
Even after hearing these stories, it wasn't clear to me why lawmakers felt the need to amend the Constitution and give themselves control over the JQC. I didn't see how that would fix whatever problems there were. As I've said, the Speaker of the House wouldn't talk. Neither would the representative who allegedly left the Santa Claus voicemail. So I found someone else.
即使在听了这些故事后，我还是不清楚为什么立法者觉得有必要修改宪法并给自己对JQC的控制权。我没看出那将如何修复存在的任何问题。如我所说，众议院议长不愿交谈。那位据称留下圣诞老人语音留言的议员也不愿谈。所以我找到了另一个人。
I'm Wendall Willard. I'm a state representative, state of Georgia.
我是温德尔·威拉德。我是乔治亚州州众议员。
Next thing we're reading about is there's an indictment being taken out against Judge Williams. I said, wow, she must have really done something pretty drastic to have a felony indictment.
接下来我们要读到的是对威廉姆斯法官的起诉书。我说，哇，她一定做了什么非常激烈的事情才有重罪起诉。
I looked this up. What she'd done, according to the indictment, was lie to the JQC. It's a felony offense with possible jail time.
我查了一下。根据起诉书，她所做的是对JQC撒谎。这是一种重罪，可能面临监禁。
Is your position basically like, maybe it was correct that she stepped down for what she did, but the idea that she would--
你的立场基本上是，也许她因为所做的事辞职是正确的，但她会因为——的想法——
I'm not concerned about her stepping down. It's the process-- what I call the due process--
我不关心她辞职。这是流程——我所谓的正当程序——
Willard says these judges think they're coming in for an informal conversation, so it seems unfair to him that they can get charged with a felony if they misremember or mis-state something. He says the whole point of these meetings is to try to work things out. Most judges just need a little counseling, like the judge who imploded under a barrage of F-bombs.
威拉德说，这些法官认为他们是来参加非正式谈话的，所以如果他们记错了或说错了一些事情就可能被控重罪，这对他来说显得不公平。他说这些会议的全部意义在于尝试协调解决。大多数法官只需要一点建议，就像那位在连珠炮般的粗话中崩溃的法官。
If every judge who goes to talk to the JQC has to worry about being charged with a felony, what judge would ever come talk to them? He says the same thing that happened to Amanda Williams also happen to Judge Becker, the one who said she was yelled at and recorded without her knowledge. She later faced six felony charges for making false statements in that meeting. The charges were dropped, but in the end, she had to promise not to be a judge again.
如果每个去和JQC谈话的法官都必须担心被指控重罪，还有哪个法官会去和他们谈话？他说，发生在阿曼达·威廉姆斯身上的同样的事情也发生在贝克法官身上，就是那位说她在不知情的情况下被大喊大叫并被录音的法官。她后来在会议上因作虚假陈述面临六项重罪指控。指控被撤销了，但最终她不得不承诺不再做法官。
The JQC has changed its policy since then. It no longer records its meetings with judges. But Becker said she felt sucker-punched by the whole thing.
JQC自那时起改变了政策。它不再录音与法官的会议。但贝克说她觉得被整个事情暗算了一把。
That is one segment of the concern that was growing.
那是担忧不断增长的一个片段。
Is that reason enough to, like, dismantle the whole JQ--
这是拆除整个JQC的充分理由吗——
I didn't say that was the reason alone, did I? Did I? We're not trying-- it's not a dismantling. I keep hearing that term used by the press. It is a reconstituting of the JQC. And to do so is going to require a constitutional amendment.
我没说那是唯一的原因，我说了吗？我说过吗？我们不是在尝试——这不是拆除。我一直听到新闻界使用这个词。这是对JQC的重组。要这样做需要宪法修正案。
I asked Willard if I could just run down the things his opponents say is happening here, to play the other side's narrative for him. Actually, I had a whole list written out on a sheet of paper.
我问威拉德我是否可以把反对者说正在这里发生的事情梳理一遍，为他演示另一方的叙事。实际上，我写了一整张纸。
I asked him why one of the co-sponsors is the guy who had allegedly left the Santa Claus voicemail. Willard said the co-sponsor thing-- that was kind of his fault. He says he'd just gone out looking for legislators to sign on.
我问他为什么发起人之一是那位据称留下圣诞老人语音留言的家伙。威拉德说那个发起人的事情——那算是他的错。他说他只是出去找议员签字。
Maybe the better part of valor would be to leave him off the bill, but I didn't think of it that way. It just didn't come to mind as being that issue.
也许勇气的最好部分是不让他出现在法案上，但我没那样想。它没出现在我的脑海里成为那种问题。
It was a pretty embarrassing thing. He'd left, like, a voicemail for an attorney telling her she could sit on his face.
这是一件相当令人尴尬的事情。他给一位律师留了一条语音留言，告诉她她可以坐在他的脸上。
I don't know what the story is. I don't know want to know about it, either.
我不知道那个故事是什么。我也不想知道。
I asked about the vote trading in the Senate. He said, I don't know. That's the Senate's side. I look back at my paper. What else you got, he says?
我问了关于参议院票数交易的事情。他说，我不知道。那是参议院那边的事。我看着我的纸。你还有什么，他说？
What else you got?
你还有什么？
Uh, yeah. I got a list.
嗯，是的。我有一个清单。
Find something important you want to talk about.
找到一些你想谈的重要事情。
OK. Uh--
好的。嗯——
I'm about through.
我快讲完了。
There are people who say the reason this was put in the Constitution was to keep it out of the hands of politicians, and you're undoing that.
有人说把它写进宪法的原因是为了不让它落在政客手中，而你正在撤销这一点。
It's still in the Constitution. It's a constitutionally-created body.
它仍然在宪法中。这是一个宪法创建的机构。
[INAUDIBLE] we feel there's a way it has to be changed that will improve upon that.
（听不清）我们觉得有一种必须改变的方式可以改善它。
Which is to give the legislature power over more seats?
也就是给立法机构对更多席位的权力？
Give the legislature the right to make necessary changes. You know, the legislature is made up of the people who elect them. We're not some animal out here, and we create other agencies and bodies all the time.
给立法机构做出必要改变的权利？你知道，立法机构是由选举他们的人组成的。我们不是这里的什么野兽，我们一直在创建其他机构和实体。
I can see how Willard sees things. He thinks the JQC needs bigger fixes. And he figures, who better to fix it than us lawmakers? People voted us into office. We are the people's representatives. And voters will have the final say. This is going to be on the ballot next month, so people will have to decide which of these stories makes more sense to them. Or maybe they'll just hear one of the stories. That will make the decision easier. Frankly, I can't imagine most voters even know what the JQC is.
我能看出威拉德是怎么看待事情的。他认为JQC需要更大的修复。他想，还有谁比我们立法者更适合修复它？人们投票让我们上任。我们是人民的代表。选民会有最终决定权。下个月选票上就会有这个，所以人们将不得不决定哪种故事对他们来说更有意义。或者也许他们只会听到其中一个故事。这会让决定更容易。坦率地说，我无法想象大多数选民甚至知道JQC是什么。
This referendum is not an example of democracy at its finest, though it's probably a pretty good example of how democracy actually is.
这次公投不是民主处于最佳状态的一个例子，尽管它可能是一个相当好的例子，关于民主实际上是什么样的。
Dave Kestenbaum is one of the producers of our program. Coming up, one of the stars of Hamilton sings the words that Barack Obama is not saying but might be thinking. We are not sure if he's thinking this. We made this up. That's a minute, from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
戴夫·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，汉密尔顿的一位明星将唱出巴拉克·奥巴马没有说出但可能在想的话。我们不确定他是否在想这个。我们编造的。那是来自芝加哥公共广播电台的一分钟，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, the sometimes-frightening chasm between the way the two sides in this election see everything. We take stock. We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Aw, Do we NAFTA?
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，选举中两方对一切看法之间有时令人恐惧的鸿沟。我们进行评估。我们已经到达节目的第三幕。第三幕，啊，我们要做NAFTA吗？
So the one big thing this year that it has felt like the presidential candidates are not disagreeing about is free trade. But it's weird. Both parties used to agree free trade is good. This year, they seem to be agreeing it's bad.
所以今年一件感觉总统候选人没有分歧的大事是自由贸易。但很奇怪。两党过去都同意自由贸易是好的。今年，他们似乎同意它是坏的。
During the primaries this year, when Bernie Sanders, Donald Trump, and Hillary Clinton were out bad-mouthing deals like the TPP and free trade in general, I had this feeling, like, wait, is it supposed to be good or bad? Like, I can't even tell anymore. Like, what happened? I felt genuinely confused about what to think. Are these deals good or bad? And so I asked Jacob Goldstein from NPR's economics podcast Planet Money to come in and just help me briefly weigh the pros and cons of these deals.
今年初选期间，当伯尼·桑德斯、唐纳德·特朗普和希拉里·克林顿都在诋毁TPP和一般的自由贸易协议时，我有一种感觉，就像，等等，它到底是好是坏？就像，我甚至分不清了。就像，发生了什么？我对该想什么感到真正的困惑。这些协议是好是坏？所以我让NPR经济播客《Planet Money》的雅各布·戈尔茨坦进来，帮我简要权衡一下这些协议的利弊。
I'm here. I talked to a lot of economists. I woke up in the middle of the night thinking about economic models of trade deals.
我来了。我和很多经济学家谈过。我半夜醒来思考贸易协议的经济模型。
I like that I asked you to come in, and you heeded the call, and then you lost sleep over it.
我很高兴我让你进来，你响应了号召，然后你为此失去了睡眠。
I-- it's true. It's all true.
我——这是真的。这一切都是真的。
That's so great and sad at the same time. So, all right. Let's start with the obvious downside of these trade deals. We lose jobs, as a country. And the number that we hear when it comes to NAFTA is 700,000 jobs we've lost.
这既伟大又悲伤。所以，好吧。让我们从这些贸易协议明显的缺点开始。我们作为一个国家失去了工作。关于NAFTA我们听到的数字是70万个工作岗位损失了。
Yeah. I mean, 700,000 people is clearly a lot of people, right? It's football stadiums full of people.
是的。我的意思是，70万人显然是很多人，对吧？那是足球场挤满了人。
Yes.
是的。
And if you are one of those people, NAFTA was really bad for you. So that's certainly true, and that's real. If you zoom out a little bit-- I mean, one thing. So that number-- that 700,000 number is over about 15 years.
如果你是那些人之一，NAFTA对你来说真的很糟糕。所以这当然是真的，那是真实的。如果你稍微拉远一点——我的意思是一件事。所以那个数字——那个70万的数字大约是15年来的。
OK.
好的。
So that's 700,000 jobs over 15 years. Just for context, the economy-- like, say, this year, is adding about 200,000 jobs a month. 200,000 jobs a month. So already this year, the US has added more than 700,000 jobs.
所以那是15年内70万个工作岗位。为了背景，经济——比如，今年，每个月增加大约20万个工作岗位。每个月20万个工作岗位。所以今年，美国已经增加了超过70万个工作岗位。
So wait, wait, wait. So I just want to be sure I've got these numbers right. So we're adding, like, 200,000 jobs a month.
所以等等，等等，等等。所以我只是想确保我得到了这些数字。所以我们每个月增加大约20万个工作岗位。
Yeah, a little less than that. But about that, yeah.
是的，稍微少一点。但大约是那样，是的。
And this is, like, a crazy boom time and that's super unusual?
这像是一个疯狂的繁荣时期，那是超乎寻常的？
I mean, it's a little high. But, like, normal would be, like, I don't, 150,000. Something like that. 130,000.
我的意思是，它有点高。但是，就像，正常情况会是，我不确定，15万。类似那样。13万。
So we're adding 200,000 a month right now, and this is 700,000 over 15 years.
所以我们现在每个月增加20万，而这是15年来的70万。
Yes. And, I mean, to be clear, it doesn't mean that there are 700,000 fewer jobs in America than there would have been. It's not like a hole, right? These jobs went away and other new jobs were created.
是的。而且，我的意思是，很清楚，这并不意味着美国的工作岗位比本来应该有的少了70万。它不像一个洞，对吧？这些工作消失了，其他新的工作被创造了出来。
Right. But the thing that we always hear-- and Donald Trump has said this many times-- is that the good jobs are gone. Like, the good high-paying factory jobs, those are gone. Making cars in Detroit-- that's gone. And what we have instead are these kind of lousy lower-wage jobs.
对。但我们一直听到的——唐纳德·特朗普多次说过——是好工作没了。就像，好的高薪工厂工作，那些没了。在底特律制造汽车——没了。而我们拥有的却是那种糟糕的低工资工作。
That's true, and it's mostly not because of NAFTA. I mean, there are-- millions of factory jobs have gone away and, that's because of automation. Jobs for people with low skills are lower-paid partly because unions are weaker, so there are a lot of reasons it's been a really bad time to be a low-skilled worker in this country. Mostly not NAFTA.
那是真的，而且主要不是因为NAFTA。我的意思是，有——数百万工厂工作岗位消失了，那是因为自动化。低技能工人的工作工资更低部分原因是工会更弱，所以有很多原因导致这个国家对于低技能工人来说是一段非常糟糕的时期。大多不是NAFTA。
So in other words, don't blame Hillary Clinton and NAFTA, blame the robots.
所以换句话说，别怪希拉里·克林顿和NAFTA，怪机器人。
Yes.
是的。
OK. So that's the downside of NAFTA. And what's the positive side to NAFTA?
好的。所以那是NAFTA的缺点。NAFTA的积极一面是什么？
So there's--
所以有——
'Cause we are not hearing much about that.
因为我们没有听到太多关于那个的消息。
No, it's true. So there's two things. I mean, this is true of trade deals in general. There's two big upsides. And one of them, when politicians are selling trade deals, they talk about, and that is, we get to sell more stuff to other countries, right? They lower their tariffs, we get to sell more stuff to them.
不，这是真的。所以有两件事。我的意思是，这对一般贸易协议都适用。有两个巨大的优点。其中一个，当政客们在推销贸易协议时，他们谈论它，那就是，我们可以卖更多东西给其他国家，对吧？他们降低关税，我们能卖更多东西给他们。
And has that worked out?
那奏效了吗？
Yeah. Yeah, we sell a lot more stuff to Mexico than we used to.
是的。是的，我们卖给墨西哥的东西比以前多得多。
OK.
好的。
The other one-- the other one politicians almost never talk about, but it's huge in economics. It, like, goes all the way back to Adam Smith. It is the central idea. And that is, trade deals mean we get to buy stuff for cheaper.
另一个——另一个政客们几乎从不谈论，但它在经济学中是巨大的。它，就像，一直追溯到亚当·斯密。它是核心思想。那就是，贸易协议意味着我们能买到更便宜的东西。
In other words, people in Mexico and China are making stuff with their lower wages, and then they sell it to us and it's cheaper to us.
换句话说，墨西哥和中国的人用他们更低的工资制造东西，然后卖给我们，这对我们来说更便宜。
Yes.
是的。
And so we live a little better because of that. And has anybody tried to, like, actually name the dollar amount that each of us makes on this? Like, how much do each of us make on NAFTA or the TPP?
所以我们因为那个生活得稍微好了一点。有人试过，像，实际上命名我们每个人从中赚取的美元金额吗？就像，我们每个人从NAFTA或TPP中赚了多少？
So those numbers are hard, because there's lots of different things going on in the economy, and there's definitely ranges of estimates. But for NAFTA, one study I found by a guy at Yale that seems, like, very reasonable-- it uses pretty standard assumptions-- he found that in the US every year, we get an extra $15 billion because of NAFTA.
所以那些数字很难，因为经济中发生了很多不同的事情，并且绝对有估计的范围。但对于NAFTA，我在耶鲁大学发现的一项研究似乎，像，非常合理——它使用相当标准的假设——他发现美国每年，因为NAFTA我们额外获得了150亿美元。
That's $15 billion, with a B.
那是150亿美元，带B。
Yeah.
是的。
Every year.
每年。
Yes.
是的。
Wow. And that's a combination of us exporting more stuff, and also we all save money on stuff that we import.
哇。那是我们出口更多东西的组合，而且我们也都在进口东西上省钱。
Exactly.
正是。
So $15 billion a year is what the whole country makes. And when you divide that by the number of us in the country, how much is that?
所以每年150亿美元是整个国家赚取的。当你把它除以国家里我们的人数，那是多少？
So it's something like $100 per worker, per year. Which clearly is, like, pretty small, right? I mean, one of the striking things about NAFTA in general is that, when you look at the US economy as a whole, the economic effects of NAFTA are just not that big of a deal, plus or minus.
所以大约是每个工人每年100美元。这显然是，就像，相当小，对吧？我的意思是，NAFTA总的来说一个惊人的事情是，当你查看整个美国经济，NAFTA的经济影响加加减减真的不是那么大。
That blows my mind too, to hear you say that, the way people talk about it.
听到你这么说也让我大吃一惊，就像人们谈论它的方式。
Yeah. I mean, I think a lot of trade is symbolism.
是的。我的意思是，我认为很多贸易是象征意义的。
And let's just go back for a second, OK? If it's 700,000 people lose their jobs, and then I only get $100 a year-- I don't know. $100? I think maybe I'd rather have somebody in Detroit keep their job. I got $100.
让我们退一步，好吗？如果70万人失去工作，然后我每年只得到100美元——我不知道。100美元？我想也许我宁愿底特律的某个人保持他的工作。我得到了100美元。
I mean, that is reasonable. You know, I think one of the reasons trade is so unpopular is, the pain is really concentrated and visible. And the benefits are really diffuse, right? Like, emotionally, like, who cares about $100? I mean, what economists would say is, in the long run-- in the long run, one trade deal after another, they add up, right? We all get significantly richer because of trade.
我的意思是，那是合理的。你知道，我认为贸易如此不受欢迎的原因之一是，痛苦真的很集中和明显。而好处真的很分散，对吧？就像，从情感上说，就像，谁在乎100美元？我的意思是，经济学家会说的是，长远来看——长远来看，一个接一个的贸易协议，它们加起来，对吧？我们所有人因为贸易变得显著更富有。
In the case of a trade deal, there is this transition period where there is real pain for a lot of people. After the transition is over, we keep getting that extra money forever. And the transition is over.
在贸易协议的情况下，有一个过渡期，在那期间很多人有真正的痛苦。过渡结束后，我们继续永远得到那笔额外的钱。而过渡结束了。
OK. So overall, the economy is bigger.
好的。所以总的来说，经济更大了。
Yes. And that right there is why economists love free trade. It's one of the few things that almost all economists agree on. In fact, there's this survey that the University of Chicago did where they asked all these economists, all across the political spectrum, are Americans better off on average because of NAFTA? 95 percent said yes, 5% said they were unsure.
是的。而且就在那里，这就是为什么经济学家热爱自由贸易。这是几乎所有经济学家都同意的少数几件事之一。事实上，有一个芝加哥大学做的调查，他们问所有这些经济学家，跨越政治光谱，美国人因为NAFTA平均来说过得更好吗？95%说是，5%说不确定。
How many said no?
多少人说不？
None. Nobody.
没有。没人。
Nobody said no?
没人说不？
Not one economist said Americans are worse off on average because of NAFTA.
没有一个经济学家说美国人因为NAFTA平均来说过得更差。
And when it comes to the TPP, the Trans-Pacific Partnership?
当谈到TPP，跨太平洋伙伴关系时？
Very good.
非常好。
So when we do estimates on how much we all might get if that were to go into effect-- like, how good are we going to do, each one of us, from that?
所以当我们做估计我们所有人如果那生效可能会得到多少时——就像，我们要表现得有多好，我们每个人，从中？
So the federal government estimate of that is, once it's fully phased in, will be about $60 billion, with a B, richer every year, we'll get that extra money. So if you do that per worker, it's like $375 per worker.
所以联邦政府对此的估计是，一旦它完全分阶段实施，每年将大约富裕600亿美元，带B，我们将得到那笔额外的钱。所以如果你按工人算，大约每个工人375美元。
Every year.
每年。
Every  year.
A little under $400 per worker gets that money.
每个工人不到400美元得到那笔钱。
Yeah. And, I mean, that's just dividing the total value by the number per worker. They're not saying everybody is going to make that much more money. And just to be clear, this is a super rough estimate. You know, nobody knows exactly what it's going to be. And I should point out one more thing about the TPP, and that is, a lot of the opposition to the TPP is not about what we've been talking about. It's not about reducing tariffs. It's about all this other stuff, like rules about patent protection, or what happens if a company doesn't like a regulation in a foreign country. TPP gives them ways to challenge that regulation. Some people don't like that.
是的。而且，我的意思是，那只是把总价值除以每个工人的数量。他们不是说每个人都会赚那么多钱。而且只是要清楚，这是一个超级粗略的估计。你知道，没有人确切知道那会是多少。而且我应该指出关于TPP的另一件事，那就是，很多对TPP的反对不是关于我们一直在谈论的东西。它不是关于减少关税。它关于所有这些其他东西，比如关于专利保护的规则，或者如果一家公司不喜欢外国的某种规定会发生什么。TPP给他们挑战该规定的方式。有些人不喜欢那样。
But the big picture with these trade deals is, like, a small number of workers get bonked on the head, and then the rest of us get a bigger economy.
但这些贸易协议的大图景是，就像，少数工人被敲了脑袋，然后我们其余人得到一个更大的经济。
Yes, although it is leaving out another piece, which is the other countries.
是的，尽管它遗漏了另一块，也就是其他国家。
Jacob, I have two words to say to you. America first. Like, really? You want me to care about the people in the other countries?
雅各布，我有两个词要对你说。美国优先。就像，真的吗？你想让我关心其他国家的人？
You don't have to care about them. But, I mean, it's a fact that when the US trades more with people in poor countries, they get richer. And that is, for them-- maybe not for you, but for them-- a big deal. China is, like, the big case here, right? In the last 20 years, say, hundreds of millions of people-- like a whole America of people have come up out of, like, grinding, you know, subsistence farming, $2-a-day poverty basically because of trade with rich countries.
你不需要关心他们。但是，我的意思是，这是一个事实，当美国与贫穷国家的人贸易更多时，他们变得更富有。而且这对他们来说是——也许对你不重要，但对他们——一件大事。中国是，就像，大案例，对吧？在过去20年里，说，数亿人——就像整个美国的人已经从，就像，艰苦的，你知道，生存农业，2美元一天的贫困中基本因为与富国贸易而走出来。
And clearly there's pollution because of that. Clearly those are terrible factory jobs.
而且显然因为那个有污染。显然那些是可怕的工厂工作。
Right.
对。
But it has been an incredible anti-poverty program for China. There's this one example from Vietnam that's, like, really clear. What happened with Vietnam was, in 2001, the trade barriers with the US came down, like all of a sudden. Not all the way down, but--
但这对中国来说是一个令人难以置信的脱贫计划。有一个来自越南的例子，是，就像，真的很清楚。越南发生了什么是，2001年，与美国的贸易壁垒降下来了，就像突然间。不是完全降下来，但——
Tariffs were dropped.
关税被削减了。
Yeah. They got a lot lower.
是的。它们低了很多。
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
And this economist in Canada realized like, oh, here is this natural experiment where we can just see-- like, there's a very clear before and after. What happens?
而且加拿大的一位经济学家意识到，就像，哦，这里有一个自然的实验，我们可以看到——就像，有一个非常清楚的前后。发生了什么？
Right. There wasn't free trade, now there is free trade.
对。之前没有自由贸易，现在有自由贸易了。
Freer. Much freer.
更自由。自由得多。
Right.
对。
Yeah. And what he found-- so he looked at what happened in Vietnam over just the few years after this change happened. What he found was, in three years there were a quarter of a million factory jobs created.
是的。而且他发现——所以他查看了这种变化发生后仅仅几年内越南发生了什么。他发现的是，在三年内有25万个工厂工作岗位被创造了出来。
These are clothing?
这些是服装？
Yeah, like textiles. Like, it's low-end manufacturing, right? Yes. Like, cheap stuff. You know, what we would think of as very bad jobs, right? So there was this quarter of a million factory jobs. And then around those jobs this whole sort of economy grew up, these people at the factory jobs were now richer. They could buy more stuff, so--
是的，像纺织品。就像，它是低端制造业，对吧？是的。就像，便宜的东西。你知道，我们会认为是糟糕的工作，对吧？所以有这25万个工厂工作岗位。然后围绕那些工作这种整个经济成长起来，那些在工厂工作的人现在更富有了。他们可以买更多东西，所以——
Oh, people selling them food and apartments and all that sort of stuff.
哦，人们卖给他们食物和公寓所有那类东西。
Exactly. Exactly. And so you have millions of people coming out of poverty in three years. In three years, 7 million people come out of poverty in Vietnam. The poverty rate for the country falls by a third. And to be clear, that is not all because of this one trade deal with the US, but it is a big chunk of it.
正是。正是。所以你有数百万人三年内脱贫。在三年内，越南有700万人脱贫。该国的贫困率下降了三分之一。而且要清楚，那不全是这个与美国的一个贸易协议的功劳，但它占了很大一部分。
I mean, when you say that, the thing I picture is like, oh-- it's almost like there's, like, a certain amount of misery in the world, and then when we lower the trade barriers we import a little misery to the United States and a certain number of people lose their jobs, and we export a certain amount of our prosperity, and they get to have the prosperity.
我的意思是，当你这么说时，我想象的东西是，就像，哦——几乎就像世界上有，就像，一定数量的痛苦，然后当我们降低贸易壁垒时我们进口了一点点痛苦到美国，一定数量的人失去了工作，我们出口了一定数量的我们的繁荣，而他们能够拥有那繁荣。
The sort of classical economics answer to that is, in fact, when you have freer trade, the total amount of misery in the world declines. Yes, there are some people who get screwed, but on the whole the US gets richer and Vietnam gets richer. It's not zero sum.
那种古典经济学的答案是，事实上，当你拥有更自由的贸易时，世界上的痛苦总量下降了。是的，有一些人被搞砸了，但总的来说美国变得更富有，越南变得更富有。这不是零和游戏。
Right, but some individuals get screwed.
对，但一些个人被搞砸了。
Absolutely. That is absolutely true.
绝对。那是绝对真的。
I thought you were going to say the idealistic argument is, like, world peace. Like, if we're trading with each other, we don't kill each other or something.
我以为你会说理想主义的争论是，就像，世界和平。就像，如果我们彼此贸易，我们就不会杀死彼此或者某种东西。
Also that one. Sure. World peace.
也那个。当然。世界和平。
Jacob Goldstein. You can download the great show he co-hosts, NPR's Planet Money podcast wherever you get your podcasts.
雅各布·戈尔茨坦。你可以在任何你获取播客的地方下载他联合主持的伟大节目，NPR的Planet Money播客。
Which brings us to Act Four, Seriously?
这把我们带到了第四幕，真的吗？
Facts, evidence, reason, logic, an understanding of science. These are good things.
事实、证据、理性、逻辑、对科学的理解。这些都是好事。
Well, the sometimes-fact-free utterances of one of the candidates for president this year has been such an issue that several times Barack Obama has spoken about facts and their importance over the last few months. At the Rutgers University commencement this spring he talked about how we live in a moment when, quote, "opinions masquerade as facts, and the wildest conspiracy theories are taken as gospel."
嗯，今年其中一位总统候选人有时脱离事实的言论已经成为一个问题，以至于过去几个月巴拉克·奥巴马多次谈到事实及其重要性。在今年春天的罗格斯大学毕业典礼上，他谈到了我们如何生活在一个时刻，引用，“观点伪装成事实，而最狂野的阴谋论被视为真理。”
When our leaders express a disdain for facts, when they're not held accountable for repeating falsehoods and just making stuff up, while actual experts are dismissed as elitists, then we've got a problem. Look, our nation's founders-- Franklin, Madison, Hamilton, Jefferson-- they were born of the Enlightenment. They sought to escape superstition and sectarianism and tribalism and know-nothing-ness. They believed in rational thought, and experimentation, and the capacity of informed citizens to master our own fates. That is embedded in our constitutional design.
当我们的领导人表达对事实的蔑视，当他们因重复虚假信息和编造东西而不被追究责任，而真正的专家被斥为精英主义者时，我们就有问题了。看，我们国家的缔造者——富兰克林、麦迪逊、汉密尔顿、杰斐逊——他们生于启蒙运动。他们寻求逃离迷信、教派主义、部落主义和无知。他们相信理性思考、实验，以及知情公民掌握我们自己命运的能力。那是嵌入在我们宪法设计中的。
There's this thing that we've been talking about here at our program, that Donald Trump probably would not have happened if there had not been a black president. You know, like, Trump rose to prominence among Republicans as the leading proponent of the idea that Barack Obama was not born in the United States. And the sudden visibility that we're seeing of white nationalism during this presidential race-- that is hard to imagine if there had not been a black president right before it.
我们在这里的节目中一直在谈论这件事，如果没有一位黑人总统，唐纳德·特朗普可能不会发生。你知道，就像，特朗普在共和党人中崛起为巴拉克·奥巴马不是出生在美国这一观点的领先倡导者。而且我们在这次总统竞选中看到的白人民族主义突然可见度——如果之前没有一位黑人总统，那是很难想象的。
Donald Trump is one of the consequences of the Obama presidency. And we've been talking about how that's probably a thought that's occurred to the president. But, as far as we can tell, he has not spoken about that publicly. And so wondering what his thoughts might be, we decided to try something. We asked a songwriter, Sara Bareilles, to write a song imagining Barack Obama's thoughts on that and on Trump, and we present that now.
唐纳德·特朗普是奥巴马总统任期的后果之一。我们一直在谈论这可能是一个总统已经想到的想法。但是，据我们所知，他还没有公开谈论过这一点。所以好奇他的想法可能是什么，我们决定尝试一些东西。我们请了一位词曲作者，萨拉·巴雷里斯，写一首歌，想象巴拉克·奥巴马对那件事以及对特朗普的想法，我们现在展示它。
Sarah puts out albums of her own, but she also wrote a Broadway show, Waitress , and she invited a Broadway colleague to sing this, Leslie Odom Jr., one of the stars of Hamilton . Here's the song.
萨拉发行自己的专辑，但她也写了一部百老汇剧，Waitress，她邀请了一位百老汇同事来唱这个，小莱斯利·奥多姆，汉密尔顿的一位明星。这就是这首歌。
[MUSIC - SARA BAREILLES, "SERIOUSLY"]
（音乐 - 萨拉·巴雷里斯，“SERIOUSLY”）
(SINGING) Let's start with hope. I threw it in the mirror like a skipping stone, the ripples won, son of a gun. Some would not have thought so, but I stand here, Commander-in-Chief.
（演唱）让我们从希望开始。我把它像一颗跳跃的石头扔进镜子里，涟漪赢了，孩子，枪的儿子。有些人不会这么想，但我站在这里，总司令。
And I take that seriously.
我严肃对待这一点。
But along the way, a rogue ripple turned tidal wave in reaction to what I tried to do, the rebirth of a Nation's hatred, red, white, and blue. Is black in there, too? Seriously.
但一路走来，一个流氓涟漪变成了潮汐波，作为对我尝试所做之事的反应，国家仇恨的重生，红、白、蓝。黑色也在里面吗？真的吗。
One man rewriting the book on bad behavior. Maybe cheats the neighbors. Feels he gets what they paid for. We can't pat him on the back and send him on through. No man's ignorance will ever be his virtue.
一个人正在重写关于不良行为的书。也许欺骗邻居。感觉他得到了他们支付的东西。我们不能拍拍他的背让他过去。没有人的无知会永远是他的美德。
Is this the best we can be? Seriously.
这是我们能做到的最好吗？真的吗。
Let's talk of fear and why I don't bring it in here. It's a dangerous word, spooks the herd, and we all bleed in the stampede. Fear makes a false friend indeed. And I take it seriously.
让我们谈谈恐惧以及为什么我不把它带到这里。这是一个危险的词，惊吓了兽群，我们都在奔涌中流血。恐惧确实制造了一个虚假的朋友。我严肃对待它。
Oh, hear me now, for the truth gets drowned out by a demigod flexing. A demigod flexing. He's history repeating.
哦，现在听我说，因为真理被一个半神在炫耀中淹没了。一个半神在炫耀。他是历史的重复。
Angry.
愤怒。
Am I angry?
我愤怒吗？
You ask, am I angry?
你问，我愤怒吗？
And I'm at a loss for words. After all we've done, every battle hard won, every hair gone gray in the name of this place, in a history plagued with incredible mistakes. Still, I pledge my allegiance to these united, divided states.
而我失去了语言。在我们所做的一切之后，每一场战斗艰苦赢得，每一根头发因这个地方的名字变灰，在一段充满难以置信的错误的历史中。仍然，我誓言效忠于这些联合的、分裂的州。
Seriously.
真的吗。
Let's end with, why? It's a question I want to ask of us as a populace. Why not take our time for the weight of this story?
让我们以为什么结束？这是我想问我们作为一个民众的问题。为什么不花时间去了解这个故事的重量？
Seriously.
真的吗。
Leslie Odom Jr., singing words and music by Sarah Bareilles. We also shot a video of Leslie Odom Jr. singing this song. It'll be up online soon.
小莱斯利·奥多姆，演唱萨拉·巴雷里斯的词曲。我们也拍摄了一个小莱斯利·奥多姆演唱这首歌的视频。它很快会在网上发布。
Well, our program was produced today by Dana Chivvis and Susan Burton. Our production staff, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Research help today from Christopher Swetala and Michelle Harris. Music help from Damien Grave.
好吧，我们的节目今天由达娜·奇维斯和苏珊·伯顿制作。我们的制作人员，佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、凯伦·达芬、伊曼纽尔·佐齐、斯蒂芬妮·傅、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。今天来自克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉和米歇尔·哈里斯的研究帮助。来自达米恩·格雷夫的音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia, who is so tired of dealing with radio hosts. They are so spoiled.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所，传递给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他厌倦了与电台主持人打交道。他们太被宠坏了。
People stand up when they walk in the room, they stand up when they leave, they bring them coffee, they laugh at their dumb jokes.
人们在他们走进房间时站起来，在他们离开时站起来，他们给他们拿咖啡，他们对他们的愚蠢笑话大笑。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。